So let's down define what does it
mean for caches to be coherent.
Intuitively, they're coherent when the
whole thing behaves like there was no
caches.
But let's define more precisely
what exactly does it mean.
There are three requirements for
coherence.
The first one says that the read,
let's call that read R,
from some address X on some core C1 will
return the value written by the most
recent write, let's call that write W,
to the same location, and
that write was on the same core C1,
if no other core has written to that
location between the accesses w and r.
So this first part of
the coherence definition
really says that if one core is
operating on a location alone,
then its reads should be getting the
most recent writes from the same core.
This basically says that a coherent
behavior includes correct
unit processor behavior as long as the
location is accessed by only one core.
The second part of the definition
says that, if core C1 writes
to our location X, and
C2 reads X after a sufficient time,
and if there are no other writes that
happen in between C1's write and
C2's read, then C2's read must
return the value C1 wrote.
So pretty much, if there is a write and
the read happens sufficiently after that
write, then the read has to read what
the write wrote, except if there
was another write in between,
in which case the read is allowed to
return that value instead of this one.
So this part of the definition
really prevents the case when,
for example,
C1 writes something to its own cache,
C2 reads forever from
its cache a stale value.
To be coherent, if C1 writes,
then after some sufficient time,
C2 must start reading the new value,
even if maybe a normal cache with no
coherent support would just keep reading
the stale value because
it never gets replaced.
So we have to do something in order to
make this part of the finishing work for
private caches, that the caching
data in a coherent system.
So we must do something to make
this caches behave this way.
And finally, the third part of the
definition says that if there is more
then one write to the same location,
then these writes must be serialized.
That is any two writes
to the same location
must be seen to occur in
the same order on all the cores.
What this part of the definition really
says different cores should not be able
to disagree about which write occurred
first and which occurred second.
Note that second part of the definition
doesn't really require this to happen.
Let's say there was one write on C1 and
another write on C3.
When C2 reads, it's allowed to return
after a sufficient time either C1's or
C3's value, because it's
allowed to interpret this order
as either C1 and then C3 wrote,
or the other way around.
What this part of the definition says
is that whatever C2 sees, if C2,
for example, sees that final
value is that from C1 and
not from C3, then all the other cores,
when they're in their location after C2,
need to also see that order.
So, it cannot happen that
C2 thinks C1 wrote last.
Some other core, sometime later,
reads and still sees C3's value.
So, what this is really
saying is that everybody,
including the writing cores,
will see the value that
is consistent with there being some
particular order to the writes.
It doesn't require any particular order.
For example, the writes can happen
almost simultaneously, in which case,
we are free to choose which happened
first and which happened second.
But we cannot allow some
cores to think that
one write was first and other cores
think that another write was first.